Extend the first finger of your dominant hand.
And now you've got five seconds to trace a capital Q on your forehead.
Some people draw the Q in a way that can be read by someone facing them,...
...with the tail on the left side of their forehead.
If you did that, then you tend to be aware of how other people see you...
...you're happy being the center of attention and you're a good liar.
Other people draw the Q so they themselves can read it...
...with the tail on the right-hand side of their forehead.
If you did that then you tend to be more of an introvert and not very good at lying.
So if you want to gain a quick and fun insight into somebody,...
...just ask them to draw a Q on their forehead.